With work, studying or a stressful schedule,
it can be *hard* to find the time or energy
for that extra edge in the bedroom. But, could
science have a solution to our sexual woes?
It just might...
Sexual desire in both men and women is controlled
by your hormones. When something triggers
you to be ‘turned on’, the brain and nervous
system send signals to your pelvis, causing
blood vessels to dilate. You experience an
increased heart rate, while your brain releases
norepinephrine, dopamine and other pleasurable
neurotransmitters which make it clear to your
body that you’re having a good time.
And humans have long tried to enhance this
biological response throughout history. Unfortunately,
there is no real scientific evidence to the
pop culture myth that oysters, chocolate or
other so called ‘aphrodisiacs’ will make
you horny. And while Viagra may prolong an
erection, contrary to popular belief, it actually
doesn’t make you more aroused. It works
solely to inhibit an enzyme so blood flow
to the penis is increased, and only acts on
the peripheral nervous system. So popping
the blue pill won’t increase libido, nor
will an erection occur without initial stimulation.
Not to mention, it has no effect on women.
But it turns out that scientists may have
mistakenly stumbled upon a new sex secret...
In an effort to create sunless tanning agents,
scientists were researching melanocortin - a
specific protein in the brain which can control
skin pigmentation. Except, when 10mg of the
synthetic version called melanotan-II were
injected in a male, an immediate and unstimulated
erection lasting 8 full hours occurred along
with nausea and vomiting. At 2.5 mg the erection
lasted 2-3 hours with minimal nausea. But
after bringing the dose to 1.25 mg, the males
were aroused and had consistent erections
without any nausea. Surprisingly, this drug
is now being effectively administered as a
nasal spray - ‘sniff-a-stiff’ anyone?
On top of which, the drug works on females
too.
When female rats were injected, along with
other hormones such as β-estradiol-3-benzoate
and progesterone, they increased hops, darts,
and ear wiggling in front of their male counterparts.
These are all actions designed to cause sexual
arousal, and invite male rats for sex.
But, before you run out to find this seemingly
miraculous love elixir, just know that it
hasn’t been approved or regulated anywhere
in the world yet. However, its derivative
called bremelanotide, is currently undergoing
human clinical trials as a potential treatment
for a myriad of sexual disorders, such as
female sexual arousal disorder. And since
the main mode of action occurs directly in
the central nervous system, it works on both
sexes.
So eat your avocados, oysters and chocolate
for sustenance...and let science handle the
sex.
Special thanks to Audible.com for supporting
this episode and giving you a free audio book
of your choice at audible.com/asap. Audible
is the leading provider of audiobooks with
over 150,000 downloadable titles across all
types of literature. We recommend the book
“Being Mortal: Medicine and What Matters
in the End” which tackles how medicine can
not only improve life, but the process of
its ending. You can download this audio book
or another of your choice, for free, at audible.com/asap.
And with a subscription you get one free book
a month! Special thanks to Audible for making
these videos possible!
And subscribe for more weekly science videos!